[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go
deep we get weird and we search for the
meaning of life along the way
presented by cast media and soul
[Music]
hey metaphysical milk shakers
it's me rain wilson and i'm reza aslan i
am your your partner in metaphysical
crime
that you are and you know we have an
incredible opportunity right here in
front of us
we are getting an amazing second
season launch to metaphysical milkshake
it's kind of a reboot it's kind of a
reinvention
of what we're doing how we're doing yeah
reboots are all the rage now
right they're like they're it's like
it's like they rebooted saved by the
bell
like how many spidermans have they done
how many spiderman i can't keep track
what happened to toby mcguire
let's reboot metaphysical milkshake why
not this is exciting
this is actually really exciting we have
a new partner in cast
media it's very exciting and we've got
an a video component
hello look we've got a camera yes yes
which i've
obviously dressed for yes you you look
amazing
you know what's great about the video
component of this version
this iteration of metaphysical milkshake
is that you can see our pandemic weight
that that is true you can actually
experience it
but i've i've had pandemic weight for
like
eight years yeah i could just blame the
pandemic for it
so listen reza and listeners we thought
that this episode would be
a little kind of introduction or
reintroduction
into metaphysical milkshake what we're
doing on the show
why we're doing the show and why we're
here
isn't that right yeah you know the the
every time we talk about this podcast
every time you know we're on getting
interviewed on tv or on the radio or
whatever
what's the first thing everybody asks us
well they are like
this is an unlikely duo how did you guys
meet each other how did
you know this famed uh religious
scholar uh provocateur raconteur
best new york times best-selling author
tv personality
reza aslan meet the um
kind of has been unemployed former
sitcom actor rayne wilson
but i will say in all seriousness um
reza
and i met um when i got to read his
magnificent
uh book zealot and we met through some
mutual friends
and i was just struck immediately by
here is a fellow journeyer
on the pathway of life on the pathway of
life's
big questions reza loves you know
everything from science to theology
everything from
philosophy to uh you know sapiens
uh by noah hariri you know all of the
life's
biggest possible questions reza has an
incredibly
sharp mind and quick wit and a facile
deep knowledge on these topics i'm
speaking about you i've shifted into the
third person i'm gonna come back to the
i'm gonna come back to the second person
and say i was
really excited one time when we had
breakfast together and we're like
let's have let's continue this
conversation that we're having about the
meaning of life
and the universe and just do it in
podcast form
yeah and listen people who know you know
this about you but like
your legions of fans around the world
think of you
as an actor and you know a a comedic
presence on
on television instagram model and
influencer
absolutely yes i've seen you in your
boxers uh
really really hot stuff i think what a
lot of people don't know about you
is that you are a deeply spiritual
deeply philosophical guy that you have
been for a very very long
time you're a devout uh baha'i
um and and that you know when you're not
acting like these are the things that
you're doing you're reading and
talking about these big existential
questions so you and i like we clicked
right away yes that is true reza and in
fact
the originating impulse for starting the
uh digital media company soul pancake uh
that i founded
was to dig into life's biggest
questions this is something that i've
always loved my entire life i was the
i was the nerdy kid at the like dungeons
and dragons sleepover
who'd be like in the middle of the game
like or as we're getting ready in our
sleeping bags to turn off the lies like
hey guys what do you think happens when
we die yeah you know i
i can see you doing that right now yeah
and you know i grew up a member of the
baha'i faith so my family was always
open to and exploring other religious
traditions but not just religion
philosophies and you know looking at
sociological studies and
psychology and um some of those books
man's search for meaning drama of the
gifted child
these are books that you know really
shaped
the course of my life and and ultimately
created the company that is co-producing
this podcast but reza what is
what's the origin of your interest in
life's big questions yeah i mean it's
it's a very it's similar yeah it was
like folklore and mythology
and fantasy um sci-fi
those were the things that got me really
excited about kind of the big questions
of the world
and then um you know i kind of was able
to
focus that attention both personally on
a spiritual level
uh and act you know academically and a
professional level
um in religion and the thing that kind
of animates me most
the reason that i study religion is
because it's about sort of
who we are as human beings like how we
understand
ourselves um in the world
right uh the thing i never get tired of
saying is that
religion isn't about the things that you
believe or the things that you do it's
about who you are
right it's a matter of identity much
more than it is a matter of
beliefs or practices and and so that
really kind of
allowed me to to talk about the things
that i want to talk about
which is politics or mythology
or history or anthropology all
under the guise of kind of you know the
larger study
of religion so i remember those late
night conversations that i used to have
in college where we would all sit around
and and think really deep thoughts
and then what happens right you leave
college you get a job
you get married you're paying rent
you're paying rent you're having kids
and
it's like the deepest thought you have
is like
you know should i what what day should i
put the garbage out
to make sure i don't miss the garbage
that's as deep as it gets
so for me i mean i'll be honest there's
i have a selfish reason for wanting to
do this podcast because
this podcast allows me to kind of go
back to those
days where i used to sit around thinking
deep thoughts
you know uh and and i get to talk to
like the
all these incredible experts these
geniuses that for some reason
agree to come on our podcast isn't it
not it's weird right
who are some of these people i mean
obviously uh malcolm gladwell
uh adam grant elizabeth colbert uh we
just spoke with the brilliant naomi
klein
my assumption is that they're all just
office fans getting back to the
life's big questions thing i'll get
personal for a minute like
and i've talked about this a lot like i
have struggled and do struggle
um a lot with mental health issues
i've had depression issues anxiety
issues addiction issues
that have been kind of front and center
in my life from my 20s onwards
and to me life's big questions about
like why are we alive who are we why are
we here what is love do we have free
will
these these are central questions like
you said earlier like
to just being a human being and
there there are books and thoughts and
ideas
and writings and philosophers and
treatises
uh and concepts that they're not they
don't just live in the realm of the
intellectual and
and i think this is really important for
people to understand about this podcast
this is not like
a podcast that's an addendum to your
philosophy 101 class in college this is
this is like how do these big ideas
relate to our lives how do they make our
lives better can they become
a kind of a compass for us that we can
kind of set our north star
by the importance of some of these big
ideas can it can it give us meaning
can it can it can can it provide a kind
of a a wind in our sails and
and move us forward because i i do
believe that
there is a reason why these questions
have been haunting humanity since the
dawn of time
and you know it's it's it's it's
relevant
it can be seen in early cave paintings
in the earliest
you know the vedas and upanishads the
earliest writings
you know the torah the onto the the
greek philosophers and the and the roman
philosophers to the
to the cafes and coffee shops of the
enlightenment europe
um these this is the eternal human
struggle
you know who am i why am i here
what's my purpose and and everything
that reverberates out from some of those
central questions so
to me it's like i need this stuff
it's food for me but no i think you're
right and i think that that's
that i mean certainly you know we have
been
going around asking people to to kind of
send in to us
their their big questions about life and
and you know you look at these questions
and they're they're all so universal
right that these are obviously you know
we're going to be talking about things
that you and i are interested in but
it's clear that that thirst that we have
for a deeper meaning to life that's that
desire that we have to ask questions
that may not even have answers but to
just
revel in the question themselves these
are universal
impulses they're they're sort of ways
that
all of us as human beings strive to
know who we are and what our role is
in in this world and so they're fun
questions
they really are and we have fun with
them i mean that's i think one one thing
that's important
is that we take these questions very
seriously we just don't take ourselves
very seriously so we have a
well you know but you know we're on the
same journey
as you are dear listener we we are
not coming to these questions from a
place of
you know expertise or specialized
knowledge that's why we have these
amazing guests to come on and
you know help us make sense of some of
these life's big questions but
you know we we just want you to come on
the journey with us and another thing
that
bears noting um is that
we live in really angry divided
disunited times i've noticed and
as you said there's a universality to
these questions
and so these discussions i hope will
resonate with everyone across whatever
political spectrum or social class or
educational level or
race or gender or or whatnot because
they are universally human like where
does
memory live what happens when we die do
we have a soul mate
these are questions that people in
mongolia and the philippines and
bulgaria and bolivia are asking and
it doesn't matter your age or your
education level
[Music]
so it you know in anticipation for this
kind of first
show of the relaunch of metaphysical
milkshake
thank you we asked some of our listeners
some of our social media
followers what their life's big question
is uh and we thought that maybe it'd be
fun for this first episode instead of
having some genius come and help us make
sense of the world that
we would play the role of the genius and
uh and we'd answer some of your
big questions no and we get to hear
their actual voices and these people
i this is high-tech stuff here wow we're
not just messing around
i like this actually hear these people
okay ask these questions and then we
will do our best
yeah to answer them all right good hi i
was wondering
we always talk about the big bang theory
and how the universe started
and and on a religious and
scientific level but what was there
before the big bang
okay that's a good start
and if to even go on a religious
side of it if god created the universe
what was god doing before the universe
was created
what was there about good follow-up yeah
jesus i was kind of hoping for something
uh
you know to start a little bit easier
hey listeners uh this podcast has some
really lovely sponsors
none lovelier than better help is there
something that's maybe interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your personal goals
you know i will say reza i talk about my
therapist all the time therapy has been
really helpful and important to me yeah
but it's hard to find a therapist right
i mean it's
it's not easy so betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need to
you can start living a happier life
today visit their website and just read
some of the testimonials
so visit betterhelp.commilkshake that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p and join the over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
special offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
milkshake uh metaphysical milkshake is
brought to you by
magic spoon uh listen usually the way
that this works in the podcast world is
that like a
and a sponsor sends you some stuff so
that you can try it out
and then you can talk about it and you
know whatever they send you we're gonna
say is great
right rain we're not going to say sure
that it sucks
they sent me some boxes of magic spoon
cereal
uh it lasted maybe like 24 hours in my
household
it is so good i mean i miss cereal don't
you miss cereal
i miss cereal in this low-carb world
we're supposed to live in
it's got zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving it's only 140 calories per
serving keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb
and gmo free it tastes exactly like
regular cereal from your childhood but
it's super nutritious so go to
magicspoon.com
milkshake to grab a variety pack and try
it today and be sure to use our promo
code
milkshake easy to remember at checkout
to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in the product that it's back
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee that that means if you don't
like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
milkshake use that code milkshake and
get five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for helping us
bring this episode to life
and please send me more cereal
i'm gonna let you handle this one you
take you take the lead here
what was there before the big bang
because they they can actually figure
out how long how old it's about six
billion years or something like that
when the
when the big bang happened is it check
that i think it's more like 14 billion
wow man this is why we have experts
okay instead of us you're right it's 14
billion god
yes oh man okay 14 billion years ago
well look she brought up
uh both the the religious and the
scientific
answers to this and i think what she
probably assumes what a lot of people
probably assume is that
religion and science have two radically
different
answers to this question but what's
really crazy is that they kind of
don't i mean when it comes to religion i
would say that there's kind of
two broad answers to what was before
the big bang uh the kind of
quote-unquote
western religious traditions uh have
this idea
you know that in in in greek we say
ex nihilo right out of nothing that what
was before the big bang
nothing there was nothing before the big
bang
except god's divine presence and then
out of god's sort of conscious will
be god says in in genesis
b he commands uh suddenly
there is existence but you know the
eastern religions they don't necessarily
have this kind of
beginning and end linear conception of
time
and creation right i'm being a little
bit simplistic here but
for many eastern religions time is a
cycle
so the big bang was just the beginning
of the next
cycle and so creation and destruction
just go on and on
and on forever and here's the crazy
thing
is that if you sort of took
the scientific explanations for like
quote unquote what was behind the big
bang
they have the same answer yeah on the
one hand there are those who say well
nothing was before the big bang the
question itself
is nonsensical because there's no such
thing as before
until the big bang what we call time
is a construct that starts the second
the universe begins the millisecond that
universe begins
so you can't use the word before
if there's no such thing as time so
the question itself is moot nothing
existed before the big bang but now
as you and i know we've had this
conversation with a couple of guests
actually
on this podcast now the sort of
more dominant theory is well it was just
another big bang
that it's just big bang after big bang
expansion
and collapse and expansion and collapse
and i also know that
one of your favorite theories of all
time string theory
i do i have a bias against string theory
this is something that the listeners
will come to learn about but
there is this incredible synergy between
string theory and ancient religious
traditions especially in the hindu
kind of mythology of the god isn't there
a god
riding on the back of a turtle and it
blinks his eyes and every time there's a
new world is created but in string
theory two
there are parallel universes that happen
in every millisecond so
um it's think about light refracting
through a crystal so there isn't this
one place there's a big empty space
and then there's a boom and then there's
a bunch of stuff expanding
but that with that boom there's infinite
numbers of universes expanding
and with every decision every choice
there's another infinite universes
springing out for that so there really
is no before because
there there is simply a parallel world
in which right now i'm gesturing with my
right hand there's a parallel world in
which
i said this sentence and gestured with
my left and it keeps splitting and
splitting and splitting and splitting
and there's something kind of
beautifully cosmic about that from both
a scientific standpoint
and a religious one and i just want to
say too that you know
i know that we're of the same mind that
science and religion work together they
work hand in hand in tandem this isn't a
science versus religion kind of
conversation it's kind of like
there is one reality and religion
explains it one way and science explains
it a different way
and they they work together right
absolutely the one thing dear listener
that you are going to find out about
rain and i pretty pretty quickly is that
uh
we do not accept this whole dichotomy of
like science and religion our opposing
forces that are always at odds with each
other in fact
we have a number of guests coming up who
talk
precisely about the intersection of
science and religion what can truly be
known
about the universe through our
scientific uh knowledge
and how that so often matches what the
great religious mystics
you know of the past have been saying
all along
uh we do talk about string theory and
the multiverse with a
with a guest like matt o'dowd host of
pbs
uh space time that was a good one that
was a great one let's go to the next
question
yes my name is aiden and i have a very
serious question
um it's one of my life's biggest
questions
why can men not produce milk
but women and female animals
can wouldn't it make sense that
men could also produce milk
in the event that the mother animal or
human
dies and cannot feed the child
or baby animals that's my
uh my question
that i've always wondered so if you
could help me out he's got a point i
would really appreciate it that's a
very good point thank you aiden we're
gonna help you out with that
i mean if you think about it like
evolutionarily it doesn't make sense
he's right like if
the if like the mother dies then the
baby dies
too so like evolutionary yeah but just
look at animals like
there's gotta be a maternal animal and
then a an
animal that does the hunting like oh
this one does the nursing
this one does the hunting i mean it's
for cats it's for birds it's for
fish it's it's for it's all those
animals i don't know much about animals
but i imagine it's that
are are there any animal species where
the males lactate
too well men can lactate actually that
is a thing
that like actually human men can lactate
so can you demonstrate that right now
yes just give me one moment
it requires a little bit of squeezing
okay okay this is all the more reason
why you should
definitely subscribe okay oh i just
threw up in my mouth
listen aiden i'm gonna ask someone that
question
someone smarter than me and and then we
will come back to you
we'll get back to you we'll get back to
you on that one next
why do we have to die and is there any
proof
that there is life after death
oh that's a good one look i'm going to
be honest i thought i thought these i
thought some of these questions were
going to be sort of lighthearted and
jokey
what was before the big bang why do we
have to die
yeah okay let's do this i've never heard
that question phrased quite that way
like
why do we have to die so you know one of
the
very popular questions like if if there
is a god then why is there so much
suffering and then so for me i always go
to well
what would it be like um if there were
a god creating a universe in which there
were no suffering
what would that be like like you're born
and there's no pain going through the
birth canal
right you just you appear and you never
stub your toe
and you never get sick and nothing bad
ever happened like that's a weird
universe
that's a way weirder universe to me than
one that abides by physical laws but
so why do we have to die i i guess you
know
from from my point of view i'm just
answer it from my point of view
everyone's gonna have a different one
um we have to die because we were
born and it's part of this cycle of life
that reza referred to
previously in terms of you know the
eastern religions that
it's it's a wheel turning around so why
does the baby in the womb
have to die to the womb well because
it's moving on to its next phase
um it's next plane of existence which is
womb to world
why do we have to die we die in this
world because we're going on to some
other
plane of existence who knows what that
is and
by the way this isn't some kind of like
airy fairy like just
religion kind of talk you know the the
mass of the universe
is dark matter what if when we die we go
live in the dark matter universe
you know or one of these parallel
universes that the string theorists are
always talking about
so why we have to die is because it's
part of the cycle of life
and is there any proof of life after
death well
you know there is and it's
something we've been wanting to do on
the show was to get
uh someone who studies these near-death
experiences because when you read them
um from every culture in the world
they align incredibly there is
a you know a feeling of great love going
some down some kind of tunnel of light
greeted by loved ones kind of taking
stock of your life
and then having some kind of choice of
coming back
there are universals there that are
chilling and have been experienced by
hundreds of thousands of people now is
that proof
no i don't think it really works so i
don't think there's proof of god i don't
think there's proof of life after death
but i i think it's a super interesting
conversation and i hope
we can get to it on a future episode of
metaphysical milkshake
somebody write that down let's do that
let's do that one i definitely believe
uh in quote unquote life after death um
i don't
believe in heaven and hell or something
like that i don't even really believe in
a bodily resurrection
honestly um and i and like we've
the theme so far i believe it both on a
spiritual level and on a scientific
level i mean on a scientific level
i mean we know as kind of you you
mentioned the
the first principle right the first law
uh is uh the conservation of matter and
energy
meaning that everything that exists
now has always existed and
will always exist as long as the
universe exists that means the things
that make up you
rain the things that make up me
are eternal that's not
again that's not religion that's
science right that the matter and energy
that make me is eternal
has always existed will always exist so
the question is is
is consciousness part of matter and
energy
or not the question isn't you know will
this matter continue to exist because it
will that's a fact
the question is well my consciousness
as it exists now the matter and energy
that leads me to know that i am me
will that exist uh
yeah i i want to think so yeah i want to
i want to to feel that that is the case
right i do believe that that there is
something eternal
about who i am and that that thing
will continue long after this this body
dies but look this is
this is the first question of humanity
right the very very first question it's
the question that led to
all of our religions all of our
mythologies uh you know
our creation of our civilization as we
know it uh you know we are
obsessed with death and dear listener
death is a is a subject that we will
talk about
a lot this season a lot in your opinion
are extraterrestrials visiting
our planet and if so
are they benevolent or malevolent
i'd like to know your opinion thanks
oh i love this okay yeah for those of
you who might have heard me on my other
comedic fictitious podcast uh
dark air with terry carnation my
favorite podcast
thank you reza we get into this one a
lot but
yes so there has been zero proof of
malevolence
from any alien contact or unidentified
flying objects so
one must presuppose benevolence but
here's my question i have two big
questions
about human and potential alien
interaction one is if they're so
advanced
why do their why do we see their ships
everywhere
and they're all different shapes why why
don't they hide better
couldn't the alien if they wanted to
just monitor the human race
why are they flying around cuba and
mount shasta like
why can't they just hide on the dark
side of the moon and just have some
super binoculars that get to watch us
and listen to our
podcasts and our television shows like
the office
and and learn about human beings that
way it's just so strange to me that if
they had this
incredibly advanced technology that you
know ships that can stop and go
on a dime that they would just be flying
around you know
baltimore and chile so and the other
question is
for in terms of the alien abduction what
is this fascination
that aliens have with the human anus
look it's the one thing that aliens and
i have in common is that we both love
butts
i like human butts and i cannot lie
i absolutely believe that uh
extraterrestrials have maybe not visited
but at least monitored
our planet and by the way this isn't
just like me
talking here this is our future guest on
this season
of metaphysical milkshake av loeb who is
a you know
harvard professor and astrophysicist and
she says very clearly yes we have
unquestionably been visited
by extraterrestrials so if they had a
malevolent
intent yeah we probably would have
noticed by now
so that's actually a good point so then
that means that maybe they are
benevolent
and maybe they're just kind of you know
waiting around for us to be
ready to experience
this this reality this fact the fact is
we've never found a missing link
right so there's no there's no link
between the ape
and the neanderthal the it it just it
doesn't doesn't exist it's not like
there's a
an ape and then an ape who's a little
more upright and then an ape with this
and we haven't found any
so it very well could be that alien
sperm came down and
impregnated an ape and made a human
being so they're
they're checking out the results of
their work or maybe they're waiting
around for us to destroy ourselves
and they're gonna take a handful of
select human beings on their
ships off to see them in alpha centauri
who knows
i'm in next hey guys
what's the meaning of life
what is the meaning to have a family to
have friends
if one day we will die
what is the meaning of existence you
know
knowing that
we have a due date like the joker right
question meaning to try to build
something good or something but
if we will at the end of the day we'll
die
and sometimes even we won't be even
history
for anybody thank you and he's like
thank you what is the meaning of life i
mean well look
well there's an existential despair
behind that question yeah he's got a
supposition what is the meaning of life
if we just are going to die and it's all
going to come to naught yeah right no no
i sense that i have an idea of what i
would say the meaning of life is i think
rain would have
a an idea i guess and and i will
freely admit that my answer has changed
you know throughout uh my years
um and and this one actually does have
to do
with kind of if we're all going to die
then what's the point
as a a lot of my my
fans or listeners to metaphysical
milkshake know i have
like something like what 30 37 kids
and you know i really do feel and i know
fathers always say this parents always
say this i really do
seek my legacy in my kids and i don't
mean that in a in an unhealthy way like
i'm not like you know be like
me uh because that's the last thing i
want them to be like
but i do see like
i have a conscious
sense that i am
forming future humans
right that the experiences that i give
them
the way that i show them love the way
that i show them how to treat
you know a woman by the way that i treat
my wife around them
the way that i teach them about how the
world
works and what to do about it when it
doesn't work
it's not just kind of theoretical you
know
it really is to me a concrete experience
that oh this is what i was made to do
that my sort of primary
job as a human being
is to equip these other human beings
to be stronger better
fuller than i am your meaning of life is
in
is in being apparent yeah honestly and
and i get it not everybody gets that i
get that
this is an existential question because
the existentialists would say you create
your own meaning
and for they would say we don't know
that there's any
afterlife we assume that there's not any
afterlife
and this guy reza aslan gets his meaning
and purpose from
parenting his children other people
might get it from gardening other people
might get it from serving the poor other
people
might get it from making a lot of money
and having a lot of success and status
you know
but whatever whatever floats you about
your boat so
you know if you're going to assume
there's nothing at the end then i think
the only
course of action is to find as much
meaning
uh moment by moment as we pass through
this incredibly
fragile and precious life um and
and that's that can be the only meaning
now i view it like i stated before that
there's we start in the womb plane and
then we're here in the material world
plane walking around
and then there's some other plane
afterwards so it's our souls
and the journey of our souls which is
eternal beyond time and space and
incredibly mysterious and beautiful
and that the meaning of life has to do
with the development of this
soul journey whatever that means for you
but you know that assumes that there's
something is going to happen it's not
lights out when we die
you know uh we actually have a guest uh
this season's uh metaphysical milkshake
that we talked to uh
christa tippett uh about sort of what is
wisdom what does wisdom mean and
she had said something that i think kind
of works in this moment
which is she's talking about you know
the definition of wisdom but i think it
works just as well
uh in talking about what is you know the
purpose of this what is the meaning of
life
which is to create an
impact in those around you
right so maybe the impact is upon the
world so
some some people get to do that right
there are people who get to really
impact you know the planet impact
millions of people um
but it doesn't have to be millions of
people right it can be your children
it can be your friends it can be your
community
uh so i think that's the that's to the
question of like
why if we're all just gonna die anyway
and be forgotten about then what is the
point
i would say the point is to leave that
imprint
right on one person at least or on as
many people as you can
leave that imprint because to your
question of you know
uh do you you know what if you don't
believe in an afterlife and all that
stuff well this is
my children are my afterlife oh that's a
good that's a good one
little mini uh reza aslan souls
continuing on
propagating the seed and knowing how
fertile you are
is probably the future of the earth
there's a bunch of asl
their existence is uh
proof of my my existence
why is there anything at all
i i love this question oh that's
fantastic
it's a it's a real quick there's no
reason why there should be
anything there isn't buddhists will tell
you
well there isn't anything everything
is an illusion it's all sunyata
everything
is the void nothing exists
science will tell you that well when you
get to the
molecular level there are sort of
you know individual atoms and then the
building blocks of those atoms but
pretty much you know whatever 90
something percent
of existence is empty space right
it doesn't actually exist
yeah why is there something instead of
nothing uh
i am obsessed with this i'm not saying i
have an answer for it
i'm just saying alexander this will be
a topic of metaphysical milkshake this
season that's a promise
can we get alexander as a guest i
all i want to say is i want to quote one
of my favorite bands of all time
neutral milk hotel because in their song
in the airplane over the sea
they say how strange it is to be
anything
at all and there you have it
boom mike drop next question hi my name
is kate and i'm from minneapolis
minnesota
and i want to know how much my leg
weighs
without cutting it off or without dying
first i don't think there's a way to
figure out exactly how much
my leg weighs i'm almost
positive this is a dwight prank like
season four
episode six yes that is a question that
jim would ask dwight
um and dwight would then proceed i guess
to cut his own leg off
and bleed out on the carpet of dunder
mifflin
that's an episode i would pay to see
excellent question moving on hey friends
uh first of all a uh i just gotta say a
big fan of you both
zelda is one of my favorite books uh the
leftovers i think is one of the most
underrated shows of all time
agreed and of course like many people i
love love love the office so thank you
for
all of your work um maybe a strange
question
um from me here but i wonder if you have
any thoughts around the idea
that much of what we experience in life
is ambiguous um i grew up in a
a very structured culture and religion
in the lds the mormon faith if you want
to call it that
um where they have very specific answers
for a lot of things you're supposed to
do very specific things in life in order
to uh
you know to to reach your full potential
in the next but i can't help but wonder
you know as i've gotten older if if
there is
a tremendous amount of intent behind the
ambiguity of life
um that if there is a creator that that
entity uh left so much of this life
ambiguous in order to force us
to to really be i don't know
self-examiners to be introspective to
be seekers of truth uh and so i wonder
do you feel like
it is important for people to have a
strong sense of purpose and and to have
a truth to adhere to
or do you feel like maybe ambiguity sort
of
is part of the purpose of life well i
feel like uh
cody has got the point of the show don't
you
i mean that is that is it he hit the
nail on the head that's the whole point
of metaphysical milkshake is to
revel in the ambiguity you know we ask
a lot of big questions of our guests of
each other
we we get asked a lot of questions you
know from from our uh
listeners and yeah look we try to answer
them
we don't we don't avoid you know
answering these tough questions but we
also recognize
that maybe there isn't an answer and
that just
simply the pursuit of the question is
enough to me
the enemy of of
life and experiencing it to its fullest
is certainty
right what's the problem with religion
certainty what's the problem with
fundamentalism certainty
right uh so much of
life is about the pursuit of certainty
when in reality
maybe we should all be a little bit more
comfortable with ambiguity right right
you know there's way too much certainty
in the world and one of the things that
metaphysical milkshake
uh celebrates is the ambiguity
and one of my favorite quotes of all
time uh
which was actually written by my
namesake
the the poet and philosopher raynor
maria rilke
um is all about this ambiguity and he
says
be patient toward all that is unsolved
in your heart
and try to love the questions themselves
like locked rooms and like books that
are now written
in a very foreign tongue do not
now seek the answers which cannot be
given you because you would not be able
to live them
and the point is to live everything
live the questions now live the
questions now
perhaps you will then gradually without
noticing it
live along some distant day into
the answer and everywhere you turn on
the media
every every podcast you turn on it's a
bunch of people with a bunch of answers
and they have a bunch of certainty
and life is always more complex
it is more gray it is more complicated
than we give it credit for
and ambiguity fits right in there and
goes hand in hand
with living the questions and that's
what we're seeking to do
yeah and that's you know life is better
that way live
the question now so if you're someone
who uh agrees with us if you're someone
who
feels more comfortable with ambiguity
than certainty if you're someone
for whom the question itself is what
matters
not so much the answer have we got a
podcast for you
oh boy and how so please
follow us like us rate us subscribe to
us
metaphysical milkshake oh follow us on
social i'm at rayne wilson he's at reza
aslan
and on instagram we're at metaphysical
milkshake and on twitter we're at
meta milk podcast send us your life's
big question maybe you can use a hashtag
metaphysical
we'll track these questions down and we
may bring some of your life's big
questions
into the spotlight on our show yeah we
already got a couple of great episode
ideas uh just from
this alone so we're gonna go on this
journey come on this journey with us i
promise you we're gonna have a good time
and if anyone can figure out how to
weigh their leg please let us know
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it's produced by safa samezadeh yazd
harris lane mick demaria hashem self and
dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold and audio mixed by justin
kyle
original music is composed by jeff tang
do you remember when you and i met with
j.j abrams to
consult with them on the spiritual
mythology
of star wars and summarily
not a single jot of it was used
in the film do you remember that
experience that was one of them i
remember it it's
that's how i start conversations are you
kidding me
like i like that's when i meet people i
begin with the time that i advise jj
abrams on the spirituality of the force
in star wars i leave out the and nothing
came of it part